bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous de débat et de reportage 90
minutes pour donner du sens à
l'actualité grâce à nos experts et aux
journalistes de la rédaction de Public
Sénat et voici le sommaire de ce 20
décembre pour notre dernière émission en
direct je vous propose de cette année
2023 je vous propose de revenir sur ces
deux guerres qui font basculer le monde
dans une nouvelle ère israël veut faire
disparaître de le ramasse de la carte du
Proche Orient la contreoffensive
ukrainienne se solde par un échec et
derrière ces deux conflits c'est à la
remise en cause d'un ordre mondial
jusqu'ici dominé par le modèle
occidental que l'on assiste nos invités
analyent cette nouvelle donne dans une
minute et puis c'est une crise politique
dont on ne mesure pas encore toutes les
conséquences le vote d'une loi
immigration validée par le rassemblement
national a provoqué la démission du
ministre de la Santé Aurélien Rousseau
et le malaise de dizaines de députés
Renaissance et modem jusqu'à la
présidente de l'Assemblée yel Bron Pivet
j'étais à l'Élysée et euh à la question
qu'est-ce qui vous gêne dans ce texte
moi j'ai répondu que la question des
prestations sociales me gênait que je
n'approuvais pas le fait de de priver
une personne en situation régulière qui
par exemple peut avoir des enfants sur
le territoire français d'allocation
famili ou d'allocation logement et donc
je trouvais que le délai de carence ne
me convenait pas je l'ai dit quelles
seront les répliques de ce séisme
politique Emmanuel Macron peut-il
ressouder sa majorité on répond à ces
questions dans 3 quart d'heure mais
d'abord donc on revient sur les deux
crises les deux conflits majeurs de 2023
avec Cécile
Sixou des tirs de roquettes des attaques
sanglantes des cordes dans les rues le 7
octobre le monde se réveille sous le
choc le Hamas attaque Israël avec une
violence inouie et déclenche la guerre
depuis la bande de Gaza est bombardé
presque sans relâche nuage de fumée et
destruction les images rappellent celle
de l'Ukraine également en guerre depuis
février
2022 de conflits de fronts ouverts cela
paraissait impossible depuis la fin de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale et la mise en
place d'un ordre international mais pour
François esbourg spécialiste de Gé
politique les règles du jeu ont changé
c'est la confirmation 2023 de du du
retour à la guerre de la fin de cette
période un peu entre deux qu'on a vécu
depuis la fin de la guerre froide et
pendant laquelle la guerre était devenue
l'exception aujourd'hui on est revenu à
une forme de norme historique
c'est-à-dire la guerre est revenue comme
mode de règlement
des différents entre États et peut-être
même redevenu le mode privilégié selon
Dominique trincan ancien chef de la
Mission française auprès de l'ONU si
Poutine comme le Hamas se permettent
d'attaquer un pays voisin qui a entré en
guerre c'est parce qu'ils n'ont plus de
retenu les États-Unis affaiblis et moins
influents dans le monde ne sont plus là
pour imposer des contraintes la Russie
n'aurait certainement pas tenté
d'attaquer l'Ukraine si avait eu face à
elle une des États-Unis fermes cette
baisse d'influence des États-Unis c'est
en gros la remise en cause du monde des
années post 1945 c'est la contestation
de ce monde là qui reposait
essentiellement sur la suprémacie
américaine fin du système unipolaire pas
complètement selon François esbourg en
réalité l'ordre international serait en
pleine redéfinition à la fois bipolaire
avec un bloc États-Unis Europe contre
Chine et Russie mais aussi multipolaire
en l'absence d'un ordre multilatéral
avec des règles raisonnablement connues
et généralement à peu près suivies ben
vous retrouvez avec une
fultitude de stratégies diverses de la
part d'acteurs qui eux-mêm ont des
ambitions et des objectifs euh
différents outre l'Ukraine et Israël un
autre conflit pourrait venir
déstabiliser encore plus l'ordre mondial
celui entre la Chine et Taïwan la Chine
affiche clairement son ambition
d'invasion depuis des
mois le bilan international de cette
année 2023 ces deux conflits majeurs qui
bouleversent les équilibres mondiaux on
revit ces événements on les analyse
évidemment et on se projette aussi vers
2024 avec nos invités le général
Christophe gomard bonsoir bienvenue
ancien chef du renseignement militaire
Sylvie matellie bonsoir et bienvenue
économiste et directrice de l'Institut
Jacques Delor B naabi bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes professeur de droit
à lupec Paris- 12 consultant
international au cabinet lisias partner
et auteur de ce livre relations
internationales droit théorie et
pratique aux éditions pédon Mathieu
croissandau bonsoir Mathieu
éditorialiste politiqueonsir on va
démarrer avec euh ce 7 octobre euh on se
projette les uns et les autres à cette
date depuis quelques minutes Israël est
la cible d'une série d'attaques
terroristes du ramas et le Premier
ministre israélien Benjamin netanahou
prend la
parole citoyens
d'Israël nous sommes en guerre non pas
dans le cadre d'une opération ou d'un
exercice mais en
guerre ce matin le Hamas a lancé une
attaque surprise meurtrière contre
l'État d'Israël et ses
citoyens la situation dure depuis ce
matin nous sommes en guerre et nous la
gagnerons 2 mois et demi plus tard
Christophe gomard la la question
stratégique et militaire elle elle
demeure israël peut-il gagner une guerre
contre le ramas et puis surtout à quel
prix alors gagner une guerre contre la
branche militaire du Hamas sans aucun
doute c'est possible ça ça reste
possible gagner une guerre contre une
idéologie c'est plus compliqué ça c'est
moins possible mais militairement oui
ils iront jusqu'au bout c'est-à-dire que
depuis le début on voit bien
qu'évidemment il y a des rétisences
occidentales rétisence d'un salon de
parce que les bombardements
effectivement israéliens font beaucoup
de victimes le chiffre exact on le
connaît pas on connaît seulement les
chiffres donnés par le Hamas donc ils
sont peu peu crédible néanmoins le
nombre de victimes est assez élevé mais
ils iront jusqu'au bout dans la mesure
où ils ne peuvent plus accepter ça de
mon point de vue une
menace à partir de Gaza à partir du
teritire de Gaza et donc ils iront
jusqu'à un démantelllement complet de
cette organisation militaire du Hamas de
façon à ce que celle-ci ne renaissent
plus de ses cendres et ensuite
quelle est la suite politique ça c'est
plus difficile à déterminer mais je
pense qu'il y aura besoin effectivement
d'avoir quelqu'un qui pilote ce
territoire en étant et pour Israël en
étant sûr que il y ait pas de résurgence
criminelle à la rencontre ouisab cet
objectif militaire est-ce qui vous
semble
réaliste on peut comprendre au nom de la
raison d'État et de la sécurité de
l'État israélien que qu'un tel objectif
soit affiché et s'impose à son agenda
qui soit Ré liste on peut considérer
qu'Israël a les moyens d'atteindre de
tels objectifs mais en réalité euh
réduire cet objectif à sa dimension
militaire et serait complètement
réducteur et c'est en cela que là pour
le coup je considère que le discours
israélien relève de d'un discours fictif
d'ailleurs vous avez un certain nombre
d'officiels même occidentaux qui
soulignent un certain nombre
d'interrogations autour des objectifs de
guerre comme on dit autour de
l'opération actuelle c'est pas en
réalité ce que signifie concrètement
détruire le Hamas dans la mesure où même
si euh Israël à un moment ou un autre
fait la démonstration de la destruction
d'un certain nombre d'organes ou de
dirigeants et bien le Hamas renaîtra
sous une forme ou une autre et que
surtout au-delà de l'opération en tant
que telle euh le nom dit l'angle mort
absolu pour l'instant c'est l'après
l'après qui est forcément de nature
politique et là pour le coup ça
n'intéresse pas les dirigeants
israéliens euh alors que en réalité ce
qui s'est passé le 7 octobre c'est à la
fois une attaque de nature terroriste et
en même temps le retour tragique de la
question palestinienne à l' gendard
International Mathieu j'ai juste une
question comment on sait qu'on a détruit
le Hamas une armée régulière ça capitule
ça se rend il y a un armistice comment
ça se passe avec avec un groupe
terroriste j'imagine que ils ont éliminé
ou arrêté au moins les dirigeants
militaires et qu'ils estimont
effectivement avoir reconnu la majorité
des tunnels si ce n'est tous euh et donc
il y a plus de menac c'estàdire qu'il y
a plus de tir contre eux or aujourd'hui
il y a toujours des combattants du Hamas
qui tirent sur les soldats israélien
mais ça veut dire que c'est que Israël
qui peut décréter que la guerre est
finie ahah de mon point de vue oui sauf
sauf si les combattants du Hamas lèvent
le pouce et lèvent un bravo blanc ce qui
reste possible Syvie matellie il y a il
y a évidemment la la question de des
soutiens d'Israël derrière ce que ce que
qu'on vient d'évoquer en en en ouverture
de ce de ce débat euh et et et de ceux
qui pourraient stopper finalement le la
riposte israélienne à part les
États-Unis il y en a il y en a-t-il
d'autres d'après vous bah on on l'a vu
on l'a vu depuis le déclenchement du
conflit il y a un certain nombre de
forces en présence et au-delà alors les
États-Unis bien évidemment sont les
mieux placés parce que parce que très
proche et en même temps on se rend
compte que bah leur leur poids ne pèse
pas beaucoup dans la balance hein et
face à la à la détermination de de
l'État d'Israël
euh ce qui est ce qui est ce qui est
certain et ce qui est compliqué encore
une fois je c'est pas c'est pas mes
sujets donc je je suis très prudente
dans dans ce que je dis ce qui est
certain c'est que la guerre qui est
menée aujourd'hui et ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui et la violence pénalise très
certainement et pour très longtemps le
retour à une une certaine
normalité dans la région et ça ça va
être un véritable sujet pour la
communauté internationale pour les
décennies qui viennent et là euh la
question Vaah je crois qu'on parle tout
à l'heure de la question nord sudud de
l'Occident et des autres et cetera là
c'est un sujet où tout le monde va
devoir se mettre autour de la table tout
le monde sera fondamental autour de la
table B naab à quel point le cette cette
guerre cette ripos qui dure hein euh
affaiblit ou fragilise le bloc
occidental c'est aussi une des questions
qu'on peut se
poser disons que euh dès lors que
précisément euh les objectifs de guerre
israéliens ne sont pas de nature
strictement militaire et qu'ils ont un
coup humanitaire un coup humain tout
simplement et que ce coup humain devient
d'une certaine
manière enfin dépasse en tous les cas
les bornes de la légitime défense
invoquée à juste titre par Israël les
Occidentaux se retrouvent dans une
situation délicate pour le moins dans la
mesure où leur lign traditionnelle en
matière diplomatique c'est de mettre en
avant euh le droit international ses
règles son cadre or là incontestablement
en dépassant les lignes rouges permise
par le droit de la guerre droit
international de la guerre le droit
international
humanitaire et que parallèlement les
Occidentaux ne condamne pas et ne
sanctionne pas ce franchissement de
seuil ce franchissement de ligne rouge
on se retrouve dans une situation de
contradiction h contradiction de mesure
mais au-delà de ça contradiction qui est
soulignée par ailleurs
par les ennemis stratégiques que sont
les Russes et les Chinois et donc d'une
certaine manière renforce les ennemis
stratég on donne raison aux critiques
dont on fait l'objet Christophe gomard
sur sur les les limites du droit de la
guerre est-ce que effectivement plus
l'aripos israélienne dure plus elle s'en
affranchi est-ce que vous dites ça vous
aussi moi je vais comparer à ce qui
s'est passé lors de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale h euh est-ce que le droit de la
guerre était contre le fait des
bombardements sur saint-lau sur Le Havre
sur dres sur Berlin euh où les villes
ont été réduites détruites à 90 %
environ et le les dizaines de milliers
de morts VO les centaines de Millien de
morts est-ce qu'il y a une justice
internationale ensuite qui a condamné
les Américains les Britanniques contre
ces bombardements quel était l'objectif
des alliés à ce moment-là c'est de
détruire le régime nazi détruire un
régime criminel quel est l'objectif
israélien aujourd'hui au-delà de la
libération des otages qui est un un
sujet dans le sujet c'est bien la
destruction du Hamas donc en fait ce
qu'on s'est permis nous occidentaux
contre l'Allemagne
Nazi voyez ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'en fait c'est là on peut être gêné
c'est que les habitants de SAINT il vous
pouz le parler des Américains il regard
un mauvais souvenir les habitants du
Havre les avra également donc voyez
c'estopinion publque internationale a
changé est-ce que l'opinion publique
internationale a changé compaison
comparaison pas raison que par là c'est
queme pardon à l'époque il n'y avait pas
les Conventions de Genève le droit
internation
ououi mais je crois pas là la justice
internationale de dire si effectivement
ils ont la justice internationale à
laquelle vous pensez peut-être c'est
c'est le tribunal de nurbert il est
intervenu après pour condamner les les
dirigeants militaires et politiques
nazis mais surtout il n'y avait pas les
Conventions de Genève qui constituent
aujourd'hui le noyau dur du droit
international de la guerre donc
forcément on ne violit pas à priori ce
droit-là qui existe aujourd'hui auquel
est lié ce droit éta a été ce droit vous
dites que le droit a été floué mais
est-ce que les juges internationaux
aujourd'hui ont dit qu'Israël avait
avait atteint les limites du droit av
dépassé les limites du droit
international quel juge vous parlez de
la Cour internationale de Justice de la
Cour pénale internationale les premiers
acteurs et les premiers sujets du droit
international sont les états or
aujourd'hui les principaux alliés
d'Israël soulligne le problème que pose
cette opération au regard du droit
international du président Biden qui
parle de bombardement indiscriminé ce
qui est constitutif de crime de guerre
jusqu'au président Macron on peut pas
parler là d'alliés du Hamas ce sont les
alliés les premiers alliés d'Israël et
qui soulignentign précisment violation
droit international lequel président
Macron annoncé la création d'une
coalition anti pour détruire le hamass
et 15 jours après prend une autre
position un mot peut-être C matelli
est-ce que ce conflit parce que on a
évidemment beaucoup d'autres faits
majeurs de l'année à aborder ensemble
mais est-ce que cette guerre entre
Israël et Hamas a des conséquences
économiques sur l'économie mondiale
peut-être pas mais sur l'économie de la
zone sûrement alors très clairement mais
y compris sur l'économie mondiale
puisque alors on était déjà dans une
guerre qui avait eu des impacts
extrêmement forts c'est le l'attaque de
de de l'Ukraine par la Russie et donc
forcément les conséquences de ce
conflit-là paraissent relativement
modéré on a vu des tensions sur le prix
du baril de pétrole mais qui n'avait
rien à voir avec ce qu'avait occasionné
l'invasion l'invasion russe de l'Ukraine
il n'empêche que ça crée quand même un
climat on démarre cette année 2024 avec
des instabilités géopolitiques dont on a
l'impression qu'elle pèse de plus en
plus sur la situation économique et sur
la confiance et puis à plusieurs niveaux
vous avez aussi on a parlé tout à
l'heure de la question de la Chine et de
la Russie on sait qu'on a une Chine qui
est aujourd'hui économiquement assez
affaibli et finalement qui avait pas
forcément besoin que le monde se
déstabilise encore plus et et moi
j'interprète aussi comme ça mais je
pense qu'on va y revenir le le le les
tentatives aujourd'hui de la Chine
d'aller à nouveau discuter que ce soit
avec les États-Unis que ce soit avec les
Européens on sent que il y a quand même
un certain nombre de pays qui sont
inquits onarlera parce qu' y a un
chapitre de ce débat consacréconomie
mondiale il y a le trafic maritime Quême
TR Mar AC la mer Rouge ccgm qui ne passe
plus par là ENF les grandes
compagnies Mme vous aurez noté que par
rapport à à ce que commettent les outils
justement en mer Rouge les officiel
américains souligne le fait qu'il y a là
une violation du droit international on
y revient c'est très on y revient on va
parler de l'Ukraine avec vous Christophe
gomard on va faire le lien entre les
deux conflits parce que alors je vous ai
demandé aux uns et aux autres de nous
proposer plusieurs personnalité de de de
l'année on alors là ça a été notre choix
parmi la liste on en a on en a
sélectionné quelques-uns et alors comme
par hasard vous avez choisi de
militaires je me permets de le
signaler le général ukrainien Valérie
zalouni et le chef d'état-major
israélien her àéi quel est leur point
commun ça ça ça m'intéresse d'entendre
ça her Alevi je le connais parce qu'il a
été mon omologue lorsque j'étais
directeur du renseignement militaire je
ne connais pas Valérie zalouni ce que je
remarque c'est qu'ils ne sont pas
forcément en accord avec le le le
pouvoir politique en place h euh avec le
décideur politique et quand on prend
dans l'histoire m dans l'histoire de
France euh vous regardez l'histoire de
la Première Guerre mondiale le
commandement militaire n'était pas en
accord avec le la direction politique
euh malgré tout le militaire est là pour
obéir euh et j'allais dire obéir aux
ordres ou décisions prises par le par le
pouvoir politique néanmoins on voit bien
derrière ça qu'en fait côté ukrainien je
ne sais pas sur quoi peut déboucher
cette dissension h côté israélien la
dissension existe et on l'a bien vu avec
le problème de la de la comment dir la
loi sur la justice voul par netanahou
néanmoins aujourd'hui Israël fait
corps autour de son armée autour de tsal
qui est le j'allais dire la colonne
vertébrale de l'État d'Israël c'est un
peu la même chose en Ukraine même si les
distensions sont de mon point de vue
plus fortes la de la guerre dure depuis
presque 2 ans maintenant et la
contreoffensive a échouer donc il a
forcément une crispation autour de ces
de ces objectifs non Attin oui et vous
avez deux chefs qui de mon point de vue
sont quand même des des vrais leaders
sont des chefs charismatiques valérie
zalouni est très appréciéf si on on
croit les sondages à plus de 80 % par la
population ukrainienne je sais pas quels
sont les sondages vers ralevi mais côté
israélien il faut bien se rendre compte
que l'armée israélienne et la colonne
vertébrale pourquoi parce que tout le
monde fait son service et si vous n'avez
pas fait votre service militaire vous
n'êtes pas un paria mais en tous les cas
vous vous n'êtes pas vrai citoyen au
sens plein israélien euh c'est toute la
difficulté avec les Juifs orthodoxes il
ne font pas de service service militaire
euh mais même si je crois que cette
fois-ci les Juifs orthodoxes ont été
aidés soutenir les soldats en le
apportant la nourriture ce qui était ce
qui était une première et on ouvre la
page Ukraine pour de bon en quelques
mots évidemment ça va être difficile de
de tout résumer mais pourquoi cette
contreoffensive a échoué d'après vous
parce que d'abord le le champ de
bataille est totalement transparent
c'est-à-dire que l'effet de surprise
c'est très difficile d'obtenir uneffet
de surprise ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose c'est que je pense que
l'armée ukrainienne n pas forcément
mesuré toutes les capacités défensives
mis en place par les Russes et
finalement ils se sont affrontés à un
espèce de mur sans avoir peut-être les
la masse suffisante pour percer quand je
parle de masse c'est à la fois une masse
humaine en homme et une masse en
matériel et en munition et c'est là où
on voit les limites en réalité de de de
l'Ukraine de l'armée ukrainienne c'est
qu'en fait l'Ukraine est un petit pays
par rapport à la Russie l'Ukraine a être
soutenu par l'Occident en à la fois en
matériel et en en matière financièrement
parlant euh mais c'est une population de
40 millions d'habitants moins 8 millions
qui sont partis à l'étranger reste 32
millions face à une population de 140
millions d'habitants donc on voit bien
derrière la difficulté qui est celle de
l'Ukraine donc si on n pas cette masse
pour percer un endroit du front quitte à
perdre effectivement un certain nombre
d'hommes malheureusement pour percer et
les char suffisant et l'arterie
suffisante ben malheureusement ça n'a
pas ça n'a pas débouché ouais na
j'aurais pu vous poser la même question
concernant le conflit entre Israël et le
ramas mais ce sont on est dans dans deux
cas de figure où on peine puis que si on
se projette vers 2024 à imaginer une
sortie de conflit à imaginer une sortie
diplomatique de crise vous voyez ce que
je veux dire alors vous avez raison sur
ce point commun mais alors pour le coup
les deux conflits sont vraiment bien sûr
bien sûr mais là je me projette vraiment
dans l'hypothèse d'une sortie de crise
oui parce que quand même d'un côté vous
avez une guerre en vérité qui nous
renvoie un passé bien connu à l'histoire
de la guerre ce qu'on appelle les
guerres conventionnelles entre deux
états entre deux armées et puis de
l'autre vous avez un cas de figure plus
contemporain qu'on qualifie de guerre
asymétrique et qui nourrit d'ailleurs la
difficulté de de résoudre le conflit et
puis en même temps vous avez un autre
point commun qui n'a pas été S souligné
jusqu'à maintenant c'est la dimension
coloniale puisque la Russie de Poutine
je sais qu'on le dit pas souvent mais je
le dis la la Russie de Poutine
finalement a une vision coloniale
vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine par qu'il y a une
une posture qui consiste à nier la
légitimité de l'Ukraine en tant qu'État
souverain en tant qu'État nation
souverain et côté israélien on a affaire
à la fois à une à une armée imbriquée
intriquée dans la société civile mais
qui est aussi en même temps une armée
coloniale euh et donc cette dimension
coloniale nourrit la difficulté
également de sorti de crise dans ce
chapitre ukrainien on va parler
évidemment de de cette procédure
d'adhésion de l'Ukraine à l'Union
européenne Samia dechir va nous
rejoindre tout de suite sur ce plateau
euh bonsoir Samia bienvenue à à vous
avec donc ce ce
Tournan de l'année 2023 c'est vraiment
une des une des dates marquantes le le
le processus d'adhésion qui s'ouvre oui
Thomas il aura fallu attendre la toute
fin de l'année mais ça y est les
Européens ont donné leur feu vert pour
ouvrir des négociation en vue d'une
adhésion ukrainienne alors ça a été
décidé jeudi dernier lors du Conseil
européen réuni à Bruxelles et ce n'était
pas gagné d'avance parce que Victor
Orban le président de la Hongrie qui est
un proche de Moscou il y est fermement
opposé et tout le monde craignait qu'il
oppose son veto à l'ouverture des
négociations alors le chancelier
allemand Olaf Scholz lui a tout
simplement proposé bien de quit é la
pièce au moment où le sujet a été abordé
dans les discussions il a accepté il
s'est donc abstenu la décision a été
prise à 26 au lieu de 27 pour éviter un
véau Hongrois donc ça a fonctionné
l'Ukraine va pouvoir commencer son
processus d'adhésion à l'Union
européenne et je vous propose de revoir
tout de suite la déclaration du
président du Conseil européen quand il
l'a annoncé à la presse la semaine
dernière 10 cette décision est un signal
très fort un signal d'espoir un signal
de confiance et un choix clair que nous
faisons parce que nous sommes absolument
convaincus que l'élargissement est un
investissement dans la paix la sécurité
et la
prospérité donc la procédure le
processus est lancé ça peut prendre
combien de temps alors ça peut être très
long he Thomas ça a pris par exemple 10
ans pour la Hongrie la Pologne encore la
Croatie alors pourquoi si longtemps bien
parce qu'avant de pouvoir adhérer à
l'Union européenne un pays candidat doit
prouver qu'il remplit certains critères
qu'on appelle les critères de Copenhague
alors il y a d'abord le critère
politique avoir des des institutions qui
sont stables qui garantissent la
démocratie l'État de droit le respect
des droits de l'homme il y a critère
économique il faut avoir une économie de
marché qui soit viable et puis il y a
enfin l'acquis communautaire
c'est-à-dire la capacité du pays à
pouvoir intégrer les règles et les
objectifs de l'Union européenne alors
tout ça ce n'est pas forcément gagné
pour l'Ukraine qui va devoir mener des
réformes en profondeur et notamment pour
éradiquer la corruption qui est un vrai
problème dans le pays mais surtout tant
que l'Ukraine sera en guerre avec la
Russie il semble difficile de remplir
les critères que sont d'avoir des
institutions stables et d'avoir une
économie viable bon on se projette si
l'Ukraine réussit à remplir ses critères
bien il faudra encore lever un dernier
obstacle parce que la Hongrie si elle a
accepté cette fois-ci de s'abstenir elle
reste fermement opposée quand même à
l'entrée de l'Ukraine dans l'Union
européenne et elle n'a pas dit son
dernier mot puisque pour que l'Ukraine
entre officiellement dans l'Union
européenne si elle réussit à remplir
tous ces critères il faudra encore que
soit soit signé un traité d'adhésion
avec l'accord de tous les étatsmembres
et donc y compr
de la Hongrie merci beaucoup Samia pour
toutes ces informations euh l'Ukraine
donc qui qui entame cette cette
intégration à l'Union européenne la
Finlande bientôt la Suède qui intégre
l'UTAN si m' dit est-ce que c'est pas là
la principale défaite de Vladimir
Poutine en 2023 parce qu'on parlait de
ses succès ou en tout cas de sa
résistance militaire est-ce que là il y
a pas une défaite très clairement et
très clairement il avait parié sur
l'incapacité des Européens à réagir face
à cette invasion à s'unir face à cette
invasion et puis puis ensuite à soutenir
dans la durée l'Ukraine or depuis l'été
on sait que l'aide européenne est assez
équivalente à l'aide américaine en terme
de moyens financiers et et et le fait le
fait que les Européens à une exception
prè c'est Victor Orban et décidé
d'ouvrir ses négociations c'est très
clairement un signal qui est
volontairement d'ailleurs hein les
Européens ont vraiment conscience on a
beaucoup parlé de cet élargissement de
cette perspective d'élargissement comme
un défi géopolitique clairement ce qu'il
est c'est-à-dire c'est une façon de dire
à Vladimir Poutine voyez il y a des pays
qui ont rêvé d'Europe et bien nous on
les laisse pas tomber on leur ouvre la
porte d'ailleurs rappelons-nous avant la
guerre ce qui a ce qui a probablement
poussé Vladimir Poutine à accélérer son
opération et envahir l'Ukraine c'est le
fait que l'Ukraine se rapprochait de
plus en plus depuis quelques années de
de l'Union européenne avec une jeunesse
ukrainienne qui aspirait à qui regardait
à l'ouest on a souvent utilisé cette
métaphore qui regardait à l'ouest et
plus du tout à l'est et ça c'était un
véritable affront pour Vladimir Poutine
un véritable affront par rapport à la
puissance qu'avait la Russie à l'époque
de l'Union soviétique et un véritable
affront aussi par rapport à ses choix à
lui c'est-à-dire une population qui
regardait vers la démocratie vers le la
liberté et et la prospérité coffrait en
tout cas l'image que donnait l'Ukraine
que donnait l'Europe pardon et ce que
lui pouvait proposer à ces pays moi
j'aime bien rappeler je trouve que c'est
super important euh de rappeler le le le
PIB par habitant par exemple de
l'Estonie qui est aujourd'hui autour de
30000 dollars par an et par habitant si
vous le comparez à l'Ukraine ou à la
Russie on est dans le cas de la Russie
on est deux fois et demi plus élevé si
vous le comparez à l'Ukraine on est
trois à quatre fois plus élevés suivant
les modes de calcul donc on se rend bien
compte et l'Estonie c'était c'était
l'Union soviétique on se rend bien
compte du progrès qui a été réalisé par
ces pays et nous on s'en rend peut-être
pas trop compte à l'ouest parce que bah
on a d'autres préoccupations mais
imaginez des populations qui sont d'un
côté ou de l'autre de la fr frontière
européenne c'est c'est évident c'est
c'est pas la même vie c'est pas en 20
ans on a changé de de de modèle en
réalité ouis est-ce que ce le discours
consiste à dire que le le l'extension de
l'OTAN l'intégration de pays limitrophe
à la Russie dans l'OTAN les les
procédures d'adhésion à l'Union
européenne ont poussé Vladimir Poutine à
déclencher cette cette offensive est-ce
que ce discours il pèse
dans ces pays qui forment alors le sud
global l'expression est un peu galvodé
mais qui voilà sont en train de
rééquilibrer justement le le l'ordre
mondial est-ce qu'on l'entend de plus en
plus ce discours oui oui que moi je
l'entends régulièrement avec des des ici
en France des gens qui disent ah oui
quand même c'est voilà voilà il y a une
part de responsabilité de l'Occident
dans dans dans l'offensive russe ben
d'abord faut faut rappeler que c'est un
discours qui est défendu par Vladimir
Poutine lui-même en fait et qui
s'inscrit dans une histoire relativement
longue qui remonte en réalité à son
accession au pouvoir dès qu'il est
arrivé au pouvoir il a eu comme prior é
à son agenda premièrement le retour de
la Russie sur la scène internationale et
deuxièmement
précisément contenir si je dire
l'extension de l'OTAN qui qui était
perçu comme une menace et précisément il
a à partir du moment où l'OTAN s'est
élargi il en a déduit à contrario que la
menace existait et qu'elle représentait
un argument légitimant bah cette
agression mais aussi d'autres agressions
vis-à-vis de la Géorgie notamment même
si à l'égard de la Géorgie c'est pas le
premier argument qui avait été avancé
mais voilà il a il s'est appuyé sur ce
discours là euh qui a convaincu ou qui a
eu une vraie onde de choc ou plutôt une
une vraie influence sur la
positionition du des pays du Sud global
encore que le premier élément
d'attractivité du discours russe dans le
sud global c'est cette capacité russe à
s'affranchir de l'autorité euh
américaine ouis le fait
de et de rejeter finalement leadership
américain c'est ce qui a c'est ce qui
aujourd'hui intéresse les autres les
pays du Sud global qui cherchent
également à s'affranchir
et se départir de d'une politique
d'alignement qui qui remonte soit à la
fin de la Seconde Guerre mondiale soit
la fin de la guerre froide rapidement
parce qu'on très rapidement je trouve
que faut faire attention avec ce
discours on donne peut-être trop de voix
à la façon dont il est prononcé par
Vladimir Poutine du point de vue de
l'économiste quand on parle de ce Sud
global il y a effectivement il il y a
quand même aujourd'hui une aspiration à
vivre plutôt comme on vit dans les pays
riches et j'emploie volontairement ce
mot mais l'impression que les pays
riches veulent conserver ça pour eux ne
sont pas prêts à partager ne sont pas
prêts à diffuser ils veulent bien
diffuser leurs valeur et vous donner des
leçons de morale mais ils sont pas prêts
à diffuser leur modèle et ils sont pas
prêts à diffuser leur développement et
ça ça pèse énormément en réalité ou
alors on parle de Vladimir Poutine qui a
cru voir son pouvoir vaciller légèrement
vaciller ce 24 juin 2023 le jour du coup
de force d'evgénie Prigogine le chef de
la milice
Wagner les actions qui divisent notre
unité sont une apostasie de notre peuple
de nos compagnons d'armes qui se battent
actuellement au front c'est un coup de
poignard dans le dos de notre pays et de
notre peuple nous faisons face à une
trahison
une trahison provoquée par les ambitions
démesurées et les intérêts personnels du
chef de Wagner evgie
prig 2 mois plus tard quasiment jour
pour jour pr était tué dans un accident
d'avion Christophe gomard avec quel
conséquence sur sur l'armée russe parce
qu'on s'est posé beaucoup de questions à
ce momentlà sur la
réintégration des soldats de Wagner
comment ça comment ça s'est passé alors
pour Laus en fait le problème avec
progine vient de ça d'ailleurs c'est
qu'en fait Vladimir Poutine voulait
intégrer à l'armée russe Wagner ce que
prigogin ne voulait pas des questions je
pense bassement financière mais
aujourd'hui une partie d'entre eux a
rejoint effectivement l'armée russe
l'autre partie et on le voit aujourd'hui
en Afrique avec cette structure qui
s'appelle Africa corp euh donc une
recréation alors est-ce que cette
structure est en lutte contre Wagner oou
est-ce qu'elle prend la place de Wagner
en intégrant des des anciines Wagner ça
reste possible mais on voit bien que ces
structures que soit Wagner ou Afric corp
sont très utiles à la Russie en Afrique
en tous les cas c'est le pion avancé de
l'Afrique pour déstabiliser ces pays
africains prendre la place euh des
Français en particulier s'agissant des
pays du Sahel mais je crois pas que
c'est réellement
destabiliser l'armée russe on a bien vu
que bartmouth avait été pris grâce à
Wagner en particulier sur à divka
aujourd'hui euh c'est l'armée russe qui
est en frontline j'allais dire euh
est-ce qu'ils y arriveront est-ce qu'ils
arriveront prendre Dika on voit bien les
difficultés qui sont les leurs euh même
si ils utilisent leur artillerie quiieux
mieux euh je ne suis pas certain qu'à la
fin il n'y arrive pas mais c'est un peu
comme un bakmou c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
ils ont perdu beaucoup beaucoup d'hommes
dans cette affaire de prise d'une cité
qui sera entièrement détruite à la fin
vous parliez de l'Afrique évidemment ce
l'un des événements enfin d'ailleurs
c'est une succession d'événements
majeurs de de cette année 2023
succession de de coup d'état on vous en
propose on vous propose une date 26
juillet on est au re c'est la date du
coup d'État 2 mois plus tard écoutez ce
militant il soutient les militaires qui
ont pris le pouvoir nous soutenons le
général
Chani nous soutenons les militaires qui
ont pris leur
responsabilité ils ont écouter les cris
du peuple et ils ont décidé d'arrêter le
mécanisme du
néocolonialisme nous disons à la France
et nous disons à
l'Occident ne faites pas l'erreur
d'essayer
de stopper le processus révolutionnaire
oui vous me disz c'est pas n'importe qui
c'est Kemy Siba kemyba oui c'est un
militant très
particulier panafricain et très
antiançais oui bah justement ça ça nous
sert à lancer votre chronique Mathieu
puisque on voulait faire un bilan de la
politique étrangère du président Macron
en cette année 2023 bon c'est pas une
bonne année on dire ça comme ça on va le
dire comme ça faut dire que tout n'est
pas de sa faute le monde devient de plus
en plus compliqué voilà les crises se
poursuivent mais quand même le bilan est
pour le moins mitigé regardez on va
prendre dossier par dossier rapidement
l'Afrique justement l'influence de la
France recule après 10 ans de présence
au Sael l'armée française a dû plier
bagage depuis 2021 des régimes pchistes
on rappelle l'on contraintte tour à tour
de quitter la République centrafricaine
d'abord puis le Mali l'année dernière
cette année le Burkina Faso puis on
vient de le voir le Niger où où nos
troupes étaient stationné les Français
qui étaient appelés hier et accueillis
comme des précieux alliés face à la
menace djihadiste sont aujourd'hui
désignés comme des néocolonialistes et
concurrencés sur le terrain on l'a dit
par des influences étrangère que ce soit
essentiellement l'émice Wagner dans
cette dans dans cette régionl
Emmanuel Macron a beau avoir entamé
cette anné une une tournée africaine
qu'il a fait au Gabon au Congo bah ça
pas été un très très grand succès non
plus il a promis de tourner une nouvelle
fois la page de la France-Afrique comme
tous les chefs d'État le font depuis
désormais 20 ans pour entamer une
nouvelle ère faite d'humilité ance
environnementale mais voilà l'influence
de paris continue quand même de de
décroître tiens un autre exemple au
Maghreb les relations avec l'Algérie se
sont un peu réchauffé c'est moins pire
que ça n'a été on va dire mais
souvenez-vous le Maroc he frappé par un
séisme qui refuse l'aidere de Paris ça a
été vécu comme un camouflé alors le
dossier ukrainien maintenant alors pour
le coup Emmanuel Macron dont la relation
2022 rappelez-vous était fraîche parfois
avec volodimir Zelenski là il a des
échanges réguliers avec son homologue
ukrainien qu'il a reçu au mois de mai à
l'Élysée et si Paris a poursuivi cette
année ses livraisons de matériel
militaire notamment des des des des
blindés légers ben avec la l'enisement
du conflit là aussi la donne est en
train de changer c'est Sébastien le
Cornu le ministre de la défense qu'il
disait en septembre en visite en Ukraine
les sessions doivent devenir l'exception
autrement dit il est plus question de
donner mais plutôt de mettre en relation
les Ukrainiens avec nos industriels de
défense c'est quand même pas tout à fait
la même histoire et puis malgré des
efforts répétés et bien Emmanuel Macron
n'a pas réussi à rallier comme il le
souhaitait le fameux Sud
tout àheure la cause ukrainienne point
positif on peut dire que le chef de
l'État pesé tout son poid pour appuyer
l'ouverture du processus d'adhésion de
l'Ukraine à l'Union européenne quit à
recevoir Victor Orban comme il l'a fait
récemment à on termine avec le
ProcheOrient Paris n'est plus un
interlocuteur majeur mais là il faut
reconnaître que la perte d'influence ça
date pas non plus d'Emmanuel Macron la
perte d'influence dans la région je veux
dire le problème c'est que Emmanuel
Macron a contribué à brouiller j'is dire
davantage encore la position française
en donnant d'abord ce sentiment d'être
trop proisraélien au risque de se mettre
à dos plusieurs capitales arabes il a
d'ailleurs été alerté sur le sujet par
plusieurs diplomate français puis en
prenant vous y faisiez allusion tout à
l'heure lors de son voyage tardif
d'ailleurs en Israël cette fameuse
coalition internationale contre le Hamas
qui a fait pchit en 2 jours avant
d'appeler désormais un arrêt des
bombardements et un cesser le feu
humanitaire à Gaza on rappelle qu'il a
organisé à Paris une conférence
humanitaire pour Gaza mais pour
l'instant ces appels au cess le feu bah
ils sont comme les autres sans succès
ouais est-ce que c'est une année qui
marque une baisse de l'influence de la
France sur le plan international B
naab je le pense malheureusement mais
comme ça ça l'a été rappelé ça s'inscrit
dans un mouvement c'est pas une année
qui marque une rupture ou ça s'inscrit
dans un mouvement de fond selon moi et
qui a précédé les les deux quinquenad d'
Emmanuel Macron franchement euh lorsque
vous parlez de bilan mitigé je cherche
en fait des réussites de l'action
diplomatique
d'Emmanuel Macron mais je
malheureusement je suis sérieux pourquoi
parce que d'un point de vue diplomatique
la présidence Macron s'est ouverte par
un choix très fort je m'en souviens très
bien c'est tendre la main à Donald Trump
croire dans la dans dans la présidence
Trump on na rien obtenu en échange et
Vladimir Poutine puis à Vladimir Poutine
ce sont quand même des échecs cuisants
il il a jamais eu à répondre de ses
échecs tant mieux pour lui mais quand
même ça reste et puis si je devais
symboliser euh euh l'échec ou le reflux
français en Afrique il a un élément très
intéressant par rapport à la présidence
Macron c'est d'un côté un choix
audacieux et intéressant qui consistait
à vouloir rompre avec la France-Afrique
en passant par le canal de la société
civile c'était central dans son discours
il je pense qu'il avait raison mais en
même temps il n'a pas mis ni les moyens
ni les discours adéquate et je vais
prendre un exemple la loi immigration
aujourd'hui dont on parle et dont on va
parler dans la vous alle elle a une
résonance en AF internationale et en
particulier en Afrique dans quel sens on
on envoie depuis des années des années
même pour pas dire des décennies
maintenant autour de la question de
l'immigration une image de la France qui
n'est pas du tout à la hauteur de notre
imaginaire sur l'influence française
dans le monde je veux dire par là que et
pour symboliser un peu cette image
aujourd'hui au Parlement espagnol vous
avez un un élu de d'extrême droite qui a
cité la France en exemple à travers
cette loi je veux dire maintenant
aujourd'hui la France lorsqu'on la cite
c'est à travers ce canal et non plus la
France de 1789 la France révolutionnaire
le pays des droits de l'homme voilà donc
quand même c'est c'est quand même assez
brutal intéressant un dernier chapitre
il nous reste quelques minutes le temps
affiler trop vite concernant les bricks
l'élargissement des bricks donc Brésil
Russie Inde Chine Afrique du Sud on est
le 24 août 2023 et c'est le président de
sud-africain justement Cyril ramafosa
qui préside aussi sommet des bricks qui
fait cette
annonce nous sommes parvenus à un
consensus sur la première phase de ce
processus d'expansion et d'autres phases
suivront nous avons décidé d'inviter la
République d'Argentine la République
arabe d'Égypte la République fédérale
démocratique d'Éthiopie la République
islamique d'Iran le Royaume d'Arabie
Saoudite et les Émirats arabes unis à
devenir membre à part entière des bricks
l'adhésion prendra effet le 1er janvier
CIV matellie ça change quoi que change
ce cet élargissement des bricks alors ça
change pas grand-chose en tant que tel
mais c'est un signal de tout ce dont on
vient de parler si on regarde de l'autre
côté du miroir en réalité c'est-à-dire
ce que ce que disait mire sur le le
local et le global qui s'interconnecte
je crois que le recul de la France dans
le monde c'est un recul occidental dont
on a déjà parlé mais au-delà de ce recul
là il est symptomatique de deux éléments
un repli sur soi de l'Occident
on a eu aux États-Unis Donald Trump
Donald Trump ça a été aussi la décision
de se retirer d'Afghanistan dans des
conditions qui ont été gérées certes par
Joe Biden mais qui était le fait de
Monsieur Trump à l'époque avec un
certain nombre d'erreurs internationales
qui ont conduit à à ce à ce à cette ce
recul des États-Unis et puis une volonté
des Américains de de de de se recentrer
de d'arrêter d'être les gendarmes du
monde ça on l'observve en France on
l'observe partout en Europe ces pays
riches ces grands pays qui ne veulent
plus peser sur les affaires du monde qui
veulent d'abord profiter de leur de leur
modèle et de leur système et qui veulent
d'abord développer et promouvoir leurs
intérêts nationaux il y a cet aspect là
et puis surtout dans ce monde global
dans la mondialisation et là on va plus
sur des sujets économiques ben on a vu
la mondialisation elle a permis une
chose elle a eu plein de défauts tout ce
que que tout le monde connaît que tout
le monde répète régulièrement mais elle
a permis une chose c'est qu'elle a
permis à un
nombre jamais atteint de la population
mondiale d'accè aider un certain
développement ça a été les pays
émergents dont la Chine aujourd'hui mais
au-delà de la Chine un certain nombre de
pays et j'en viens à ces bricks parce
qu'au fond ces brisqu sont-ils si ce
n'est des pays émergents des pays
émergents d'abord économiquement qui ont
ensuite voulu peser d'un point de vue
d'un point de vue politique et qui se
sont réunis il y a quelques années c'est
assez intéressant le concept des bricks
parce qu'au départ c'est un concept
financier en fait développé par par un
économiste de Goldman sax qui est repris
par ces pays en disant voilà on fait le
lien contre l'économie on est devenu
puissant et bien si on est devenu
puissant économiquement si on a les
moyens de de de de peser et bien on veut
peser aussi sur le plan politique et
c'est face au refus finalement de
l'Occident d'entendre cette
revendication somme toute légitime que
ces pays se sont organisés une fois
qu'on a dit ça ils s'organise ils se
coalis face au retrait occidental bah il
sementent qu'il y a une place à prendre
donc ils sont de plus en plus nombreux à
vouloir se coaliser et les briques
s'élargissent et c'est un signal de ça
en réalité mais au même titre que l' été
d'une certaine manière la Route de la
Soie il y a quelques années et
l'adhésion d'un certain nombre de pays
du Sud à cette route de la soie au même
titre que l' été le la participation au
G20 d'un certain nombre de pays dit du
Sud et cetera et cetera donc on est
vraiment dans cette logique là la
question qui est posée aujourd'hui par
ces briques et qui est très intéressante
et qu'il faudra suivre c'est la question
monétaire c'està-dire aujourd'hui
domination du dollar avec les sanctions
autour du dollar avec les échanges
internationaux qui sont en dollars et
des pays du Sud qui disent bah au fond
est-ce qu'on peut pas se trouver une
autre monnaie pourquoi pas le Yan
chinois pourquoi pas une une la création
d'une nouvelle monnaie il y a eu ce
projetl donc on verra si ça va jusque-
là force de constater malgré tout que
ils ont pas encore tout à fait les clés
de la construction d'un ordre alternatif
international donc les années qui
viennent vont être passionnantes oui
Christophe gomard un dernier mot le le
le pays la région qu'on va surveiller en
2024 c'est sûrement Taïwan est-ce que
est-ce que le le risque d'une invasion
chinoise est réel comment comment des
des experts comme vous l'appréhendent ça
je pense qu'il est réel dans la mesure
où je crois que la la Chine se verrait
bien pour le centenaire de la République
populaire de Chine totalement réuni euh
et donc ça c'est
2029 49 ou ça ça nous laisse quelques
années ça nous laisse quelques années
néanmoins on voit bien qu' m une
pression militaire autour de Taiwan qui
est quand même très très forte et on
voit une présidente j'ai faill nommer
comme
personnalité3 la présidente de taiïwan
qui me paraît effectivement une
personnalité qui tient très bien son
pays et qui a envie
effectivement de résister à la Chine la
la Chine version République populaire de
Chine donc on voit bien derrière et
est-ce que les les États-Unis
soutiendront jusqu'au bout taiïwan ça
reste pour moi une question est-ce que
les Américains mourront pour Tawan ça ça
reste une question parce que le
désengagement américain il date d'avant
Trump il date depuis
Obama mandat bombarder la Syrie à
l'époque est-ce que je pourrais ajouter
juste un tout dernier mot euh sur un
personnage qui peut paraître comme
anecdotique c'est le nouveau président
argentin abier my pourquoi parce que son
élection en fait confirme confirme cette
séquence historique marquée par des
démocratie qui sont qui perdent leur
boussolle et parce que depuis le début
on parla un peu en terme de bloc alors
qu'en vérité on a de plus en plus de mal
à définir certains blocs notamment
l'opposition entre régime démocratique
et autoritaire et le le l'ARG Argentine
qui va se dessiner sous nos yeux risque
de nourrir cette confusion par les
démocrature c'est ça c'est un
MRE démocratie et dictature c'est ça
exactement regardez la première décision
qu'il a prise en tous les cas qui devra
se traduire en des termes législatifs
qui consiste à soit interdire les
manifestations soit sanctionner
systématiquement certains des
manifestants et puis ça nous projette
vers 2024 l'élection aux États-Unis et
le spectre d'un retour de Donald Trump
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce euh débat B naab je
rappelle le titre de votre livre
relation internationale droit théorie et
pratique qui est donc publié aux
éditions pédon voilà je vous dis à
bientôt sur Public Sénat on se reverra
en 2024 évidemment sur ce plateau